Speaker 1: Let's go next to let's go to Greg
Peach. Greg Peach from where where are you
calling in from, Greg?
Speaker 3:
Hello, I'm calling from Georgia.
Speaker 1: OK, very good,
you're on the air, Greg, and there's
music in the background. There's wind
chimes. There's many different things happening.
Speaker 3: I just want you to have a pleasant
experience on this call with me, David.
Speaker 1: Thank you. Know,
the wind chimes are relaxing. Go ahead.
Speaker 3: So, yeah, I have, I guess.
Shoot, I had a. Oh, I have I have a
question for you. So you still believe that
there's a population of people that will hear Joe
Biden doesn't want them to get vaccinated and will
go and get vaccinated out of spite?
Speaker 1: You're saying if if they
came to believe that Joe Biden, like, didn't
want Republicans vaccinated, they would be like,
I'll show him I'm going to go and get vaccinated.
You're asking if I think those people exist.
Speaker 3: Yeah, and you've mentioned this
before on your your show, so if I didn't,
I'm basically asking if what you
mentioned before on your show is still.
Speaker 1: I believe you have. Yeah, I think
so. I think if it and it's not it's more it's
a little more complicated than if Joe Biden said
it. If there was a narrative that Joe Biden was
going to take away the vaccine from right wingers
after a certain date, like, I know it's crazy,
right? It would never happen. But if a large
portion of the right came to believe that,
I think many of them would rush out to get
vaccinated just to spite Joe Biden for sure.
Speaker 3: So my follow up to that is,
as somebody with a widely seen news show,
do you have a moral imperative to make fake
news, to spread that narrative, to save lives?
Speaker 1: It's a beautiful question. I I think
that it would be wrong for me to unilaterally
start spreading that. And I can't actually
articulate why. But one of the things that
I try to do on this show is never to lie
to my audience about my beliefs. And so.
It fundamentally would go against my approach to
say something on the air that I don't believe to
be true specifically to trick people into doing
something. And you're you're right that I might
be doing it with the intention of saving lives by
getting people vaccinated. But it's one of those
principles that I just can't really get over the
hump and say, I'm going to lie. I'm going to say
things on the show. I know to be a lie.
Speaker 3:
OK, great. That's my question. Thank you again.
Speaker 1: All right, Greg. Now, if people
disagree with me, if people think now in that
situation, I should be making an exception,
I should be lying to my audience because
of the objective. It's a means to an end.
Let me know. I think that that would
be certainly interesting for sure.
Let's go to John from is it Lester or Lester?
Speaker 3: Last week, for the first time,
I suspected that Yankees are going to
get it wrong, but, you know, thank you.
My question for our level of ground and like a
nice lesson, is the audience being nice to you?
But I ask, are you how are you doing?
Because, like, I guess I don't know,
I watch the American news vicariously through you
as smart sources as well. The balance that just
because I lot of it is OK and it's messed up.
Speaker 1: I mean, you can't
you're cutting out a little bit. Are you
saying did you say our things messed up here?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I guess I'm more interested about
how you're doing with it, because it seems like
I don't know, I guess from my perspective of
dealing with the crap is going on in Britain.
Yeah, it's quite distressingly, you know.
Speaker 1: Oh, I see what you're saying. Yeah.
Listen, I mean, I've talked about maintaining a
healthier media diet and balance and so, like,
basically for three full days a week, I'm
tuning out of the news altogether. And I'm just,
you know, I'm doing my biking, I'm doing my
running, I'm reading, doing other stuff. I
think it particularly when there is so much
craziness going on. Really important to get
a break. And that's, I would consider it a
mental health break from the substance that I
normally consume for my job. That's my approach.
Speaker 3: Well, not as good as I thought my
question was, but it's good to get taken care of.
Speaker 1: Thank you. And things are OK in Lester.
Speaker 3: I mean, I don't know, I've been
locked out for a year and a bit, two months yet.
Speaker 1: What does it what
does it mean that you're in
lockdown? Do you go to the grocery store?
Speaker 3: Uh, well, now we do. But I say for the
first covid now, like, it was basically like you
go to the shop and then you come back and then you
just let it go. OK, I got to go outside. Actually,
that's not fair to say. I work in the NHS,
so I had to go outside, but literally my
house for about a year and maybe a bit
been living indoors, which is fine.
Speaker 1: And are you are you going
to restaurants or pubs and
sitting outside, for example?
Speaker 3: First, I went to a pub last weekend,
Speaker 1: OK, so you're no longer in lockdown.
My guess is what you're saying.
Speaker 3: No, but it like a semi
like that is weird, like, for example, at
work I wear a mask, I visit people home,
I wear a mask outside of the shops. I don't
wear a mask. It's my choice. I still ask.
Speaker 1: Got it. Got it. All right.
Very good. John, I appreciate the call.
All right. There we go. Beautiful,
pleasant phone call from Leicester,
it looks like it would be nice there, but it's
not. I learned that many years ago. A lot of
people won't tell you that, but I will on this
program. I appreciate everybody who called in.
I'm sorry I wasn't able to get to every call, but
we will take calls again, my friends. Thank you